if you love movies history and dams
you're in luck well now
the damn short film festival is offering
virtual screenings of award-winning fan
favorites by nevada filmmakers last year
the pandemic forced the festival to go
online the festival's executive director
says that opened a whole new world and a
much wider audience than in the past so
they decided to do an off-season
showcase of some of the top short films
virtually
it's something that we can really
have pride in the great talent that is
in nevada and it really gets
lets us
get to know
a lot about our state because
a lot of these films are about nevada
and people in nevada and and issues that
we face
a drama comedy documentaries even music
videos they are all available streaming
on demand right now through the end of
the month tickets are just ten bucks so
you purchase that on the festival's
website you can watch those movies all
month long at the 18th annual damn short
film festival coming up february 10th
through the 14th it's at the historic
boulder theater it draws an
international crowd big names come
through there so you never know who you
might be rubbing elbows with down in
boulder city yep boulder city beautiful
theater as well well and some of those
films become nationwide films or
globally global films you know because
sometimes a little sleepy film can
become a big hit push it through and
plus you can uh brag to your friends hey
i saw this cool movie have you seen it
yet no well because it's a limited
release it's only i saw the damn film
festival and you can show off and talk
about it with your pals right now you
just watch it on your couch all local
films and a shout out to leah lanier who
helped
get the damn short film festival going
years and years ago
he's a painter and he decided to let
other folks kind of run it but thanks to
him for keeping it going and svetlina
for uh taking it over yeah great history
there yeah plus it's just fun to invite
your friends to the hey you want to go
to the damn film festival and they're
like well gosh you don't have to be
upset about it
it's a good name damn short film
festival
never gets old never gets old i